hundreds of people in Las Vegas held a
vigil last night remembering police
officer Charleston Hartville he was one
of the 58 people killed in Sunday's
massacre Hartville was a 16 year Army
veteran with a wife and two children
people who died range in age from 20 to
67 this morning they are represented by
58 white crosses those crosses are
placed along the Las Vegas Strip
the gunman Stephen paddock booked a room
in Chicago this summer at a hotel near
Lollapalooza that's one of America's
largest music festivals it could be a
sign officials believe that paddock was
eyeing other cities and venues as
targets vladimir duthiers our streaming
network cbsn is outside the Mandalay Bay
Resort and Casino near the scene of the
shooting glad good morning good morning
investigators have been trying to
reconstruct Stephen paddocks movements
in the days weeks and months before
Sunday night's shooting spree and a new
AP report says law enforcement are
looking into the possibility that
paddock was planning further attacks
including a car bombing two months
before Stephen paddock fired into a
crowd of 22,000 country music fans in
Las Vegas
a police source confirmed the CBS news
haddock booked two rooms at the
Blackstone Hotel in Chicago haddock
never showed up but the hotel overlooks
Grant Park where Lollapalooza was taking
place the four day music festival
attracted some 400,000 people including
Sasha and Malia Obama at this weekend
Chicago Marathon
police say security will be beefed up
we're putting a significantly larger
number of undercover officers they're
gonna be intermingled with the crowd
they're gonna be around the runners
they're gonna be at the finish line
they're gonna be at the start line CBS
Boston station WBZ reports patek search
for hotel rooms near fenway park and
concert venues in the city there is no
evidence he actually traveled to Boston
Massachusetts governor Charlie Baker we
and many others are fully clothed
there's no path there is no and
in Massachusetts Haddix motive has so
far eluded investigators and one may
never be found says Randi Sutton a 23
year veteran of the Las Vegas police
that's probably the most frustrating
part of this investigation so far is
that he doesn't fit the profile that we
that anyone would have expected
investigators are also looking at
paddocks gun purchases especially the
ones he made in November and December of
last year that's when he bought a
shotgun in Las Vegas a rifle in
California and a couple of handguns at
another gun store in Nevada Alex Vlad
thanks